是一个两边有口袋的一条裤
然后面料这种滑溜的很
来这个39块扣3扣3
这个裤有一丢丢厚
春秋天应该可以这个
来这个39块扣3扣3
3939扣3扣3
39块
扣个3扣个3
来这一条黑色黑色
前面有风机裤
有拉链的这一条哈林裤
来腰围
腰围7690
76到90
腿围106114
当长40
裤长99
这个有腰的扣
这个39块
扣9扣9
腿围106117
腿围108
腿围107
腿围109
腿围108
哎呦妈呀
噢
感冒难受了
嘿
人呢人呢
陪聊一会儿
来这个
这个藏蓝色的这个是
刚刚那个是黑色
现在是一个藏蓝色
来这个腰围
腰围是76
76到90
腿围110 120
当长37
裤长是96
裤长96
这个39块
扣6扣6
39块
扣个6扣个6
藏蓝色的这一条
39扣个6
这一条
这一条尺码也大
这个尺码也大
喂
没有来
明明
你家老伙儿你打电话来
你给他打电话
好了
嗯
来这个
这个标的是4L的
巨指
这个牌子
来是一个人字纹的
这个4L的也是一个大码
你看
这个是一个大阔腿
裤腿很大的这一条
来
这个腰围
腰围88
那拉伸110
腿围130 140
当场42
裤长97
来这个
这个29给你们放个复列
29扣个1
29块
扣1扣1
29这个尺码大
29块
扣1扣1
扣2扣5
扣2扣7
扣6
扣8
扣7
扣9
扣10
扣11
扣12
扣13
扣15
扣17
扤16
扤19
扤20
扤21
扤22
扤23
扤24
扑26
扑27
扑48
扑29
扑30
这个小板群
那一块路
bankj
我看摸这个半身裙条纹条纹的这个
这个原来29的
原来是29的
M码
人棉87
巨指12
居然是1
牌子这个牌子的
这个牌这个牌
来腰尾量一下
腰尾68
68 76
臀尾90 102
裙长41
来这个9块
9块扣个5
9块9块扣5扣5
孤品了这条半裙
9块扣个5
小半裙
孤品孤品
9块
扣5
人呢人呢人呢
来这个裙
这个半身裙
后面是
Sony有拉链
A字版的一个半裙
来这一块
这个是L尺码标的是
这个是L的
然后是人棉74
尼龙23
居然是3
牌子这个牌子的
GLOB的
GLOB
来腰尾
腰尾66能拉伸78
腿尾
腿尾是106 120
裙长95
95群长95了
这个29扣3
29块
扣3扣3
这种裙最开始是49的
29了
现在全都29了
扣3扣3这一块
底下有一点鱼尾的
29块
扣个3
扣扣群出来了
已经用了
这个是啥
半身裙
侧边有拉链有弧尼扣这一条裙
这面料好垂
很舒服的
这个裙
哇
扎线了
我娘哎
回去吧
这回去
你们自己也给弄一下
去踩起来
这里扎线
我天哪
这里扎线这一条
根本就没缝起来应该是
来这个腰围
腰围的话是72
72 84
寻常寻常是80
寻常80我看还有其他小子不
这里脏了一点
9块钱给你们9块
底下还有一点点脏
9块9块
扣2扣2
扣个2就在这里没有缝起来
里面有一个这个内衬
9块钱9块钱小苹果
你看这里可能他忘记给缝了
脏在最底下
脏在这里在这里
这个能洗掉不知道粘的啥家伙
冲在地上粘的啥家伙看看
边边上底下底下最底下
边边上脏了几点点
然后唯一的那个那个能洗掉
然后这个这个应该
他忘记给缝起来了
可能是忘记缝了
你看呗他这个踩的针眼都没有
你回去给他缝缝对
你这个合缝的地方他就没有缝
你看呗
他这里都是弄的好好的
看他主要是没给踩起来
直接踩上就行了
来9块
我再给你检查一下
还有没有啥
没有其他还好
其他没有问题
其他都很好
就是这一个合缝
就他没有没有缝
这是个啥半裙
半身裙
小黄油368
乍现
先写个乍现
来
其他都很好
就那一点没有
不缝可以吗
不缝你怎么弄啊
那多难看
没有就这一条
我我之前都没过到过
你不缝的话
他都把这个内衬不露出来了吗
内衬不都露出来了吗
你随便在中间
你或者不缝的话
你把中间这个位置给他
给他定一针也行
最起码中间他出不来
那多难看
你要缝一下
要缝一下呀
你找个裁缝给你弄一下
你踩一下
这底下包边左边都很好
都是弄好的
还挺好
OK就这一条
我刚就发现了一个哈
来这个
这个两边有斜插口袋的
格子的一个半身裙
中间平肩全松拧
然后是三个颜色的这个裙
腰围68 68 112
68 112长度90
90 91纳度
这个39扣3
39块扣3扣3是一个
39 39扣个3扣个3
还有一个红色还有一个蓝色格子呢
这里面有两个灰色格子
还有一个红色的格子
这个也好看这个裙
这个裙子也好看
红色格子的一个半身裙
这个多少都是全松拧的
腰围68到11114了
这个都长度是90
来这个39扣9
39块扣9扣9这个
好了吗
都抓一拉一拉一会
哈哈哈
哎呀好可爱啊
好可爱啊
哈哈哈哈
他回老家了
你天后一炸你跑来累了吗
你俩
我天我哥这我自己还够
那老子
我想一个人清净都没有时间
哈哈
我我跟老家我就都快回来
跟老家其实也没自己的吃完饭就是
跟老家我也好累
自己就再回来太晚了
哈哈哈
吃完饭看着没人说个话
嗯那有六串没得
这没有人问我
你这要不就都上床躺着吃吧
不睡就这样了
对不对
他问我不老家就给我柳丸一来
这人家的天女啊
人家的天女啊
对
那就是上一年
一年一年你都拉下一家的花
没喝过让他睡觉
这都十一年了
大洋十二年多
你搞啥孩子再来一套
当你再来
你太厉害了
你毛好有点尴尬
哈哈哈
对不对
要怪宠食家闻了
那天天猫咧
会上门才会想哎
能不清吗
能清牙吗
哈哈哈
你闲几天你又哭了呗
就今次
闲几天你又哭了
嗯
二十几号吧今天
二十几号我我我前年发信息啊
嗯
不知道今天
我去广州他有一天来了
不知道几天
我也不知道我也
嗯
哎
不知道你看我把这一上门就拉起了
哈哈哈
就是这样
我一来就哭了
我看来我有力吧
现在跑个这个
对
我年纪
你能让他四处四处
睡不着啊
你这样睡不着啊
哈哈哈
你看你也有拉完
哪有拉的呀
哪有时候有拉的
有的时候能老有拉的吗
啊
,走啊走啊
来这个这个是
这叫啥 sm 2的 sm 2的对 sm 2全棉100的这个
开衫棉线全棉100的一个针织开衫细线针织的
棉100棉100均码均码
棉100均码 sm 2的这一块
后背的画是有一条粗纱线
后面有一条粗纱线
来胸围看一下
胸围是94116
94116来长度
长度是60长度5960的
这个有要的扣来这个1919我给你们
扣6扣6 sm 2全棉100
后背有一条粗纱线能看见吗
这里
来这个19块19块扣6扣6来货49的拿这个开衫
咳咳咳不介意的扣
1919扣6扣6应该就这一件了
扣品啊
这个好久没见过了
这个棉100棉100的
这几个都是大针织的我娘哎
来这个米色高领呢
米色高领的一个针织
这一盘
这个是高领这一款针织
看看这一个米色上身好看的
来前面全是大麻花的
胸围128152
281529哎来长度长度是55啊
长度55啊
这个29扣5啊
29块扣5扣5啊
2929扣个5
你这个厚的放一起
29块扣个5
还有一个这你知道吗
橘色的
开衫
看看这个橘色的开衫也好看
橘色橘色这个很亮的一个开衫
来胸围
胸围120150
120150的胸围长度长度68
这个39扣8
39块扣8扣8这一个
这样的一个袖子3939扣8
39块扣个8扣个8
99扣个8这里面就拣掉了
这就是这个
这个袖子的尖头
这个袖子的一些鞋子
一个拋键的针
这个带上这个底盖
这个鞋子的底盖
这个上下就是这样一个椅子
这个鞋子的这个扣就要有一个鞋子
这个鞋子里面有一个圈子
这个鞋子里面有一个圈的针
这个鞋子就有一个圈的针